[Music]
alright guys so what do you think it's
Khloe's birthday do you think I should
unblock me Kim Kardashian and Tristan
Thompson are putting the past behind
them
the pair squashed the social media beef
appropriately at Khloe's birthday party
Wednesday night Kim always giving us the
best content shared a close-up shot of
the big moment okay guys
of course
Tristan blocked Kim after the NBA star
made headlines in April for cheating on
Khloe just days before she gave birth to
their daughter true Khloe keeps posting
the most adorable photos of true how she
doing is there any yeah really really
really great yeah loving being a mom
last week a source told et Khloe and her
family have forgiven Tristan and added
that the couple is committed to
rebuilding their relationship it's
exciting it was all love at khlo money's
34th birthday soiree the family hung out
in the backyard
dancing relaxing by the fire and
enjoying a lavish candlelit dinner
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]